so you've turned to crowdfunding looks
like twice yes yes apologetics my the
first one was that 2011 yes so I'm not
sure that it's about what you're good
then that's where he could win 2010 ok
good not sure but yeah short the first
time I was a goal and what was your time
frame why do you think that happened and
then you went back in 6000k the first
the first one was first one we didn't
have anything to show we just said we're
going to make a movie and we'd love your
support we I mean our video was hastily
shot and stuff yeah i mean but we
already believe wholeheartedly believe
that we were going to do and then we
could do it so we were raised 70 grand
but would you have any concrete stuff to
show I mean that we had a script and we
knew that we were ready to make the
movie but I mean how does the audience
know that I mean I we didn't do our
homework full up in regards to
Kickstarter and what works and how you
construct videos I mean it was just like
jobs and somebody later was explaining
you guys look like you just got back
from some vacation camping vacation and
he decided to shoot this witch yeah but
Jimmy more elastic I mean it was just we
improvised one take and then used it or
and they cut it up a bunch of times um
yeah so we failed miserably well how do
we think we hit out what do we have like
five thousand dollars six days of that
yeah so we get zoom life cuz we failed
sorry well it's all or nothing wrong she
said you had some backers were they
people that you knew all right but it's
most of them were people that we knew
most of its but on Kickstarter it's all
or nothing oh yeah yeah yeah so and then
the second campaign um we set up after
we had shot the film the film was
already done yeah we had you know we
were submitting the film to festivals
and we were looking to raise additional
funds to support or to supplement the
festivals and additional things that we
wanted to add to the film
like a coloration if we if we were gonna
go down that road or or salad we had a
new from a dr war which was a pain in
the neck so those dollars were ultimate
and telling legal fees that was another
big one cuz then we had to immediately
hired attorney those which was a very
smart idea um you for me i'll see yes
what all that was done at the very
beginning of the process um advise you
one that's a lot of times people don't
always yeah oh yeah just start shootin
yeah no I mean I did I in pre-production
before once we had the phone call I then
started crushing through a lot of books
about production and and and production
law as well just did so that I would
cover that I at least pretend that I
knew what was going on to cover both of
us and the people that were involving
themselves in this ridiculous venture so
thankfully I learned just enough to keep
us above water and then once the film
was finished then we got the attorney to
make sure all the contracts were done
properly and thankfully most work yeah
and the ones that weren't we uh we then
just had them her redraft um okay yeah
hey that's pretty good yuri draft new uh
contract so that everything was legit
yeah so what do you think was different
when we're back to crop on the second
you raise what 15 thousands yeah it was
like 14 8 or something like that that's
how I know that was our goal yeah we did
we had I think we head over there's
something around there so but the
different the difference was that we had
a trailer to show and that people
actually like the trailer so that made
all the difference in the world you got
to have something to say this is what
your funding and I can rather than
something you know yeah there's a lot
more obscure now is that was comic
creators like now we had finished
product this is what we need to do can
York we need to come up with some funds
to supplement the these actions and
luckily we were able to raise some of
that money but I mean yeah yeah we were
lucky we were lucky too because that
definitely did help and the food for the
whole process with some of the same
initial backers that were from the first
campaign today did you go back to them
and if so what did you say and did they
jump back on oh I mean we didn't really
say any contacted anybody specifically
we just checking out a new message you
know and a lot of those same people and
you know plus many more I'm actually
yeah I came through big time I mean I
mean it definitely helped quite a bit we
never think a lot of people realize even
for a film let's shout credit cards and
with virtually no budget how much money
it takes to finish the project and then
to release the project to the
distributor and to do it by the book
legally so there are I mean it's a lot
of money to do or to come up with for a
again a no budget film and we were lucky
because I definitely that helped us out
when you told people about Kickstarter
and how did you tell people whether it
was an old college buddy or hmm someone
in your neighborhood back home I pretty
much do facebook so if people didn't
know what it was they could cook click
Lincoln and check it out um I didn't I
don't remember a lot of quad I mean it
maybe I'm not remembering correctly
because this is sort of been a traumatic
experience I'm sorry no not do not a
damn yeah no we can't make you regress
back to anything no no not not the kicks
I'm saying though um I always being
facetious the fill the whole a whole
film process but uh Kickstarter's great
though cake survey it's very cool you
know working with this was the first
time working with Kickstarter was with
oconomowoc and it was really cool just
be able to browse the different projects
that people are were here there's some
awesome awesome projects on there and
there that's pretty neat it's pretty
cool um platform that they offer but to
connect your question I mean I don't
know I don't remember if we were getting
a lot of questions like what is
kickstarter um people we sent out the
leg and then it just sort of was spread
through facebook like people were
posting it over and over again kind of
felt bad actually yeah when people were
just getting blown up links all day yeah
by not only by us but by other people
like we were posting on our pages and
the oconomowoc the film page but the
relatives and the fans of oconomowoc the
film page were then posted so it was
getting a lot of exposure in a short
amount of time yeah this is a great
thing yeah which is great thing so I
don't know oh I think they just figured
out what Kickstarter was by then going
to the link and watching and reading and
there's a Q&A section in or a fact
section anna and on your kickstarter
page that really spells it out for
people so I mean I'm sure we had to have
had questions like what's Kickstarter or
like what what is it you guys are doing
by that
everyone was pretty well aware that we
made a film and that we were going to do
some fundraising and most of these
backers were all people that you knew
personally or people who knew someone
you say the majority definitely people
that we use through some kind of
connection but I'd ever definitely some
organic you know funders that we didn't
know yeah which is really cool to see
when you're looking at your backer
report every you know every day a couple
times sometimes yeah I don't know who
that person is that's really cool that
they were intrigued enough to you know
give some of their own money to our
project and then pass it on as well it's
pretty cool then you eat a cue track and
you see on their Facebook page they'd
posted something about it but I don't
know the exact percentage but if I don't
guess with probably someone like twenty
twenty percent of completely unique
people that that we couldn't track trace
back to any anyone that we knew so I
mean that was pretty pretty interested
did you ever feel like you were going
outside of your comfort zone in terms of
getting the message out there because
you do have to almost be like this used
car salesman for like a good month yeah
like a lot of filmmakers don't want to
do that because they don't want to be
that guy or girl yeah but did you have
to kind of cross that line a little bit
and if so how did you live with yourself
in the morning oh I think a little bit
between him and I both posting it got a
little out of hand for a short while
when you add in the movie Facebook page
but after a while if people do that for
you then the message comes from
everywhere and people kind of are like
oh well what is this thing you know so
and then it's sort of it it reduces the
amount of that you actually oppose yeah
and then you can't ban you or ever
because you're not doing anymore
we set the we send a Kickstarter page i
don't remember exactly how many days it
was but i think it might have been like
14 like it was what 14 or 18 days it was
less than 20 days i think oh i think i
might i think it was 30 days really i
think so much weight the first or second
what's the first one was 45 the second
was i think it was 18 I don't know we
can check it out somewhere between but
the kind of the curve on the graph was
kind of like you know yeah I did it
exponentially shot for exam yeah which
was nice but you know dance your
question it was I don't like doing that
at all I mean it's I don't even I don't
even like telling people about arf arf
film on the street like hey come come
come to the theater and watch your phone
you know it's I mean you you you have to
do it especially at this stage because
no one knows who we are and probably no
one really cares um hopefully that
changes hopefully we don't have to shoot
things on credit cards anymore no and we
have scripts read and hopefully some
funding but um yeah I mean all of that
stuff is ismail is my least favorite
part of the experience um the promotion
i I'm not not a big fan of that so you
say you're a little bit uncomfortable
being that sort of guy and pushing your
project but you did see how important
was the end
sort of that curve and then it spiked up
yeah I mean not a side from Kickstarter
with any it any side of the marketing
even though we don't want to be the
cheerleader we have to be the church for
our projects no one else's right now but
undoubtably it is highly highly
beneficial to spread the word about your
film or Kickstarter I mean it without us
pushing for that I don't think we would
be where we are and but you know you
have to create something relevant
something that's news something that
people want to talk about or share
they're interested in reading not just
some bland check us out yeah you know
what I mean like it's got as much right
now drinking or new well like how some
of your folks some of your works are
were a little bit self-deprecating and I
like that it was like you you know you
kind of said you kind of almost made fun
of yourselves a little bit about perks
and then also to with the quotes on on
your homepage we have a thumb you kind
of almost poked font yourselves a little
bit and I think that's an interesting
style and I think maybe that helps
people then oh that's interesting to
file away yeah whose idea was that I
mean I just think that's a similar the
one of the things what when I first met
Joe many many years ago that was one of
the few things because I don't really
like anything else about him um well
it's all going out now that was on okay
oh yeah it's that's that I think we
share that that sensibility and style of
sense of humor where we want to laugh at
everything and if we're only everything
we really want to laugh in ourselves
because we live with ourselves one so
you got to make fun I mean you got to
make fun of what you do or at least see
the humor and the majority things you
it's ridiculous we're ridiculous human
beans all of us are and so one of those
reviews you know when we first started
showing friends and family you know bits
and pieces of the movie that a lot of
you know our relatives and stuff
especially know maybe in the next
generation up we're kind of like
you know so so you know it there was
some truth you know those based on some
truth as well yeah I mean the interest
you that I mean there is you were in the
truth I mean it is what it is but um
yeah
you